- It's amazing what you can
do when you're just authentic.
It's amazing what you can do
when you're just true to yourself.
I am a woman with a beard
when a beard is supposed
to be a manly thing.
(bouncy, mellow music)
My name's Harnaam Kaur, I'm 26 years old.
I work as an anti-bullying
activist, and I model too.
Polycystic ovary syndrome
is as simple as saying
that I have more testosterone in my body
than the female sex
hormone and the side effect
of the condition is weight
gain or weight loss,
diabetes, alopecia, obviously facial hair.
In school I was bullied horrendously
because of the way that my body was.
I thought that the bullying would stop
if I removed my facial
hair so I started tweezing,
bleaching, waxing, shaving,
using hair removal creams,
but the hair growths just came back
even longer, darker, thicker.
I was at the age of 16
when I hit my lowest
and I was very suicidal, and
I was just sick and tired
of all the body shaming and bullying,
and people not letting me live
my life the way I want to,
and I thought, right, you're
gonna grow your beard out
and see how you like her and
see how she forms on your face.
(lively piano music)
I obviously look after my beard.
I've given her a name as well, Sundidi.
I think a lot of men just look at me
because my beard's just sometimes
a lot better than theirs.
Sorry.
All the negativity that I went through,
I turned into something positive
and I made a career out of it.
You know, I’m in the media absolutely everywhere,
very fortunate to, you know, to be able to reach
such a vast amount of people,
'cause there are so many women out there,
even men that suffer from body shaming
but don't speak about it.
As one woman said, "I'm not
suicidal because of you."
So that to me just really ensured to me
that what you're doing is having
a positive effect on people.
If there was a pill that
could reverse all this, no,
would never take it.
I can't say I love this,
but I don't love that, no.
100% love myself.
(chiming)